If you haven't got anything nice to say, then don't say anything at all. It's getting sped up. It's getting sped up and I'm gonna... What is it? The three-star rating is like, would be good for the conferences, but issues may exist. welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 130 recorded on may 16th 2023 my name is connor and today with my co-host bryce we interview two guests tristan brindle and ben dean in this part one of a two-part series, we recap C++ Now 2023. Anyways, let's hop into the official, well, maybe some of that will make it in, maybe some of that won't. But today we are here with, have we actually, we've done one of these for person. We did it with Chandler and Patricia. We did it with, was it you, Benricia we did it with was it you ben and
如果你没什么好话可说，那就什么也别说。它在加速。它在加速，我要……是什么来着？三星评分就像是，对会议来说挺好，但可能存在一些问题。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 130 期，录制于 2023 年 5 月 16 日。我是康纳，今天和我的联合主持布莱斯一起，我们采访了两位嘉宾：特里斯坦·布林德尔和本·迪恩。在这两部分系列的第一部分中，我们回顾了 2023 年 C++ Now。不管怎样，让我们进入官方环节，呃，也许其中一些会被剪进去，也许不会。但今天我们在这里，我们真的……我们为现场做过一次这样的节目。我们和钱德勒以及帕特里夏一起做过。我们和，是你吗，本里夏，我们和……是你吗，本，还有
tony van eerd at c++ that was three person because bryce wasn't there oh yeah yeah bryce wasn't there right right that's what i was about to say is the other time that we've done this with two guests oh yeah eric and otto oh no no we did that one too but also++ Now, like, a few years ago, I wasn't able to make it, and you did it with two guests. But as Ben just pointed out, that was only three people. So this, I think, is the third time we've got four people. We're here today with Tristan, who was one of our most recent guests. Maybe our most recent guest, actually, I think, in between a couple episodes that we did solo
托尼·范·埃尔德在 C++ 上，那是三人组合，因为布莱斯不在。哦，对，对，布莱斯不在，对，对，这就是我要说的，我们有两位嘉宾的另一次，哦，对，埃里克和奥托。哦，不，不，我们那次也做了，而且还有++ Now，几年前，我没能去，你和两位嘉宾一起做了。但正如本刚刚指出的那样，那只有三个人。所以我想这是我们第三次有四个人。我们今天在这里的有特里斯坦，他是我们最近的嘉宾之一。也许实际上是我们最近的嘉宾，我想，在我们做的几次单人
episodes. And we've also got Ben Dean, who has been on the podcast now twice, I think, once during the C++ Now interview, and then once that got turned into, I think, a four-part algorithm discussion. We will link all of the previous episodes in the show notes. Also, too, before we let Tristan and Ben introduce themselves, I had no idea. Maybe we can cut this out, too, if you don't want it. I'm not sure if you introduce yourself at talks this way now, Ben.
单人剧集之间。我们还有本·迪恩，他现在已经上过两次播客了，我想，一次是在 C++ Now 采访期间，还有一次被变成了一个四部分的算法讨论。我们将在节目说明中链接所有先前的剧集。此外，在让特里斯坦和本自我介绍之前，我真的一无所知。也许如果你不想的话，我们也可以把这个剪掉。本，我不确定你现在在演讲时是不是这样自我介绍的。
You work at Intel now. I do. I'm a principal engineer at Intel. Yeah. Since October. How did I not know? I saw this on LinkedIn at some point, and then I was like, how am I not know i saw this on linkedin at some point and then i was like how am i not aware first of all you switch companies which is just news because i think we're pretty good friends and then two sure it's to our i mean are they our arch enemies is that accurate i mean if if they
你现在在英特尔工作。是的。我是英特尔的首席工程师。是的。从十月开始。我怎么会不知道？我曾在某个时候在 LinkedIn 上看到过这个，然后我想，我怎么会……我曾在某个时候在 LinkedIn 上看到过这个，然后我想，我怎么会不知道，首先你换了公司，这简直是个大新闻，因为我认为我们是非常要好的朋友，然后第二，当然这属于我们——我的意思是，他们是我们的死敌吗？这准确吗？我的意思是，如果
would be our arch enemies if they were good i'm, since I joined, you better watch out. Now they're good at it, whatever it is. What are you doing at Intel? I work in the chipsets group. I work on the power management. I'm on the same team as Michael Case and Luke Valenti, both of whom are, as you know,
如果他们很厉害的话，他们就是我们的死敌了。自从我加入以来，你最好小心点。现在他们很厉害了，不管做什么。你在英特尔做什么？我在芯片组部门工作。我负责电源管理。我和迈克尔·凯斯以及卢克·瓦伦蒂在同一个团队，如你所知，他们两位都是
conference speakers and people active in the C++ community well congratulations on the new job it's very exciting and uh yeah thank you yeah um it is exciting well i want to i want to understand a little bit more about like what exactly why does the intel chipsets group want a bunch of c++ gurus to improve the c++ we're writing We're writing C++20 for highly constrained embedded targets. So it is an interesting and exciting thing to work on just because of the, frankly, global impact that we can have.
会议演讲者，也是 C++ 社区的活跃成员。好吧，祝贺你找到新工作，这非常令人兴奋，呃，是的，谢谢，是的，嗯，这确实令人兴奋。嗯，我想，我想更多地了解一下，英特尔芯片组部门到底为什么想要一群 C++ 大牛来改进我们正在编写的 C++ 代码？我们在为高度受限的嵌入式目标编写 C++20。所以这是一个有趣且令人兴奋的工作领域，坦率地说，因为我们能够产生全球性的影响。
We're writing the code that controls the power to inside the chip all the all the parts of the at least of the south part of the chip that's the chipsets right so do you do is there like an internally they say this many billion devices are affected when you push code well we don't say that but um but yeah i mean that's i have a i now have a moral weight on my shoulders that i didn't have when i was working in games or finance yeah yeah i mean that's what i think uh when the apple clang folks or marshall clow i've heard him say that in a few talks where you know when he's pushing code to lib c++ as i believe yeah that library um that it goes to you know billions of devices so it's potentially you know yeah certainly you know it's the same thing like if i managed to
我们编写的代码控制着芯片内部的电源，芯片中所有部分，至少是芯片南部区域的所有部分，也就是芯片组，对吧？那么，当你推送代码时，内部会有人说“多少亿设备受到影响”吗？好吧，我们不会这么说，但是，但是，是的，我的意思是，我现在肩负着一种道德分量，这在我以前在游戏或金融领域工作时是没有的。是的，是的，我的意思是，这就是我所想的，呃，当苹果的 Clang 团队或马歇尔·克劳——我听他在几次演讲中说过，你知道的——当他向 lib c++ 推送代码时，我相信是的，那个库，它会推送到，你知道的，数十亿台设备，所以它可能，你知道的，是的，当然，你知道，这是一样的，如果我设法
save milliwatts here whatever microwatts there it the multiplicative effect is huge yeah i think that i think that's one of the main pulls to working at a company like intel or nvidia is that your your the code that you work on is used by so many different people that having a small impact can have a huge effect yeah my co-worker said the other day like every one of us could like remove but like equivalent the equivalent of removing uh power multiple power stations from the world wow good job you're gonna say something tristan oh well i was pretty much gonna say that you can actually sort of affect like global power consumption levels um which is which is crazy doing a bit for uh the environment and climate change and all that stuff.
在这里节省毫瓦，或者在那里节省微瓦，其乘数效应是巨大的。是的，我认为，我认为去英特尔或英伟达这样的公司工作的主要吸引力之一，就是你从事的代码被如此多不同的人使用，以至于产生一点点小影响，也会带来巨大的效果。是的，我的同事前几天说，我们每个人都可以像移除——移除——相当于从世界上移除多个发电站的功率。哇，干得好！你要说什么，特里斯坦？哦，我本来想说，你实际上可以某种程度上影响全球的功耗水平，这太疯狂了，为环境、气候变化以及所有这些事情出了一份力。
Yeah. Andre Alexandrescu, when he was at Facebook, I remember him saying in one of his talks as well that, like, you think that some of this stuff, like, you know, fractions of a percent don't really matter. But a fraction of percent on, like, the number of devices that, like, Facebook Mobile is running on actually equals, like, millions and millions of dollars for Facebook. Right. Which is in terms of, like, the data centers that they're, you know, hosting all their stuff. Like if you can make a very small change, uh, yeah, the multiplicative effect ends up saving them like an immense amount of money, which yeah, not, not all companies, obviously, if you're a small little startup, are you going to be able to say that? Very cool. All right. Well, we, we sort of skipped the whole introduction thing because I'm not able to say that very cool all right well we sort of skipped the whole introduction thing because i'm not supposed to do that uh but yeah maybe uh if we'll
是的。安德烈·亚历山德雷斯库在 Facebook 时，我记得他在他的其中一次演讲中也说过，你认为其中一些东西，比如百分之几的小数点不重要。但对于 Facebook 运行的设备数量来说，百分之几的小数点实际上等于 Facebook 数百万美元的收益。对吧？也就是说，就他们托管所有内容的的数据中心而言，如果你能做一个非常小的改动，是的，其乘数效应最终会为他们节省巨额资金，这，是的，并非所有公司——如果你是一个小创业公司，你显然无法说出这样的话。非常酷。好吧，我们，我们有点跳过了整个介绍环节，因为我不能说这非常酷。好吧，我们有点跳过了整个介绍环节，因为我不应该这样做，呃，不过，也许，如果我们先从特里斯坦开始……我是那个不专业的人，某种程度上。嘿，你从来没有把介绍做对过，而且这也符合人设。哦，你看到了吗？但我没试过，而且我的前提是，我们不需要它们。不，我们需要。而且，这非常切合主题，因为就在试图做介绍的时候，有人——我们被称为 ADSP。那是我们的官方名称：算法加数据结构等于程序。然后我们有 ADSP：与肖恩·帕伦特的讨论。然后我们有从 Reddit 获得的非官方口号：充满信息碎片的混乱。然后肖恩·巴克斯特在最近的一期播客中回复了我们，当时我们正在讨论 Circle，
go to tristan first and i'm the unprofessional one kind of hey you never you never get the introductions right and also it's on brand oh did you see but i don't try to and i i my premise is that we don't need them no we do and also, this is super on topic because right in the midst of trying to do the introductions, someone – so we're known as ADSP. That's our official name, Algorithms Plus Data Structures Equals Programs. Then we have ADSP, a discussion with Sean Parent. Then we've got our unofficial slogan that we got from Reddit, which is chaos with sprinkles of information. And then Sean Baxter replied on the most recent episode where we were talking about Circle,
在那里你说他不听。他回推说：“你在说什么？我听了 ADHD 播客的每一集。”说明一下，我确实知道肖恩听了。我只是想稍微惹恼他一下。是的，所以现在我实际上不知道我最喜欢这三个中的哪一个了。但不管怎样，抛开这些不谈，我们将把话语权交给特里斯坦，以防万一。因为根据我们要讨论的内容，我认为这个系列，或者无论我们怎么剪辑，都会非常受欢迎。所以，特里斯坦，请继续。好的。我叫特里斯坦。这些天我主要是一名 C++ 培训师，尝试教导人们，把他们带入我们这个可怕的、
where you said he doesn't listen. And he said, he replied on Twitter saying, what are you talking about? I listen to every episode of ADHD, the podcast. For the record, I did know that Sean listened. I just wanted to rile him up a little bit. Yeah, so I don't actually know which one of those three I like best now. But anyways, that out of the way, we'll throw it to Tristan to introduce yourself in case. Because I think this series, or however much, however we cut this up, is going to be quite popular based on what we're going to be talking about. So Tristan, go ahead. Okay. My name is Tristan. I'm these days, mostly a C++ trainer, try and teach people, bring them into our wonderful world of this horrible,
可爱的工作语言的美妙世界中。你设法在我不在的情况下播了大约两三期节目，然后就忍不住把我叫回来了，非常感谢，我很高兴再次来到这里。我们确实很喜欢你，我们会在节目说明中链接特里斯坦的许多演讲，他做过许多关于 Ranges 的演讲，他接下来也将在许多会议上发表演讲，所以我们也会链接这些内容。如果你恰好在特里斯坦要去发表演讲的城市，你可以来打个招呼，参加会议，那会很棒。好的，本，你可以做一个简短的介绍，然后我们再进入，或者也许我们做一个小小的 C++ Now 回顾。但是，本，先自我介绍一下吧。好的，我叫本·迪恩。我是英特尔的首席工程师，在芯片组部门从事电源管理工作，负责编写
lovely language that we work in. You've managed to have what, like two or three episodes without me and then couldn't resist and brought me back so thank you very much I'm very happy to be here again we do like you and we'll link a bunch of Tristan's talks he's given a bunch of Rangers talks and he's also going to be speaking at a bunch of conferences coming up so we'll link those as well if you happen to be in the cities that Tristan's going to be speaking at you can come say hi attend a conference and it'll be awesome all right Ben you can give a brief introduction and then we'll enter, or maybe we'll do like a little C++ now recap. But yeah, introduce yourself first, Ben. Yeah, my name is Ben Dean. I'm a principal engineer at Intel where I work in the chipsets group on power management, programming the
芯片封装内部控制芯片其他部分电源的嵌入式微控制器。这就是我目前的工作。我偶尔也是个会议演讲者。上周我刚在 C++ Now 上做了两次演讲，介绍最好简短一点。所以就这样。偶尔做会议演讲相当谦虚。我的意思是，你脑子里有数吗？我想你大概做过——肯定很多。我不知道，数字可能是十几次？我想可能有很多，15 次左右吧。我不知道。你保留着我的演讲 YouTube 播放列表，康纳。是的，是的。我想当我们有一次邀请你做嘉宾时，本的许多演讲都在我最喜欢的演讲之列。
embedded microcontroller that is inside the chip package that controls power to other parts of the chip. That's my current job. I am a sometime conference speaker. I just did two talks at C++ Now last week, and introductions are best if they're brief. So there you go. sometimes conference speaker is quite modest i mean do you know off the top of your head i think you've probably given like gotta be way up i don't know digits maybe a dozen i think maybe a lot 15 something like that i don't know you've got you keep the youtube playlist of my talks gonna Connor. Yeah, yeah. I think when we had you on one of the times, so many of Ben's talks are like in my favorite talks.
我知道其他很多人也是这样。那么，有什么呢？易用、难误用，用类似声明式 C++ 的方式编写代码。那次演讲，我想在某个时候，可能现在依然是，我最喜欢的演讲。事实上，它排在肖恩·帕伦特的 C++ 调味之后，但它一直是前三名的演讲。有一个阶段，我经历过
And I know a bunch of other people, it's the same. So what is it? There's easy to use, hard to misuse, coding in like declarative C++. That one, I think at one point, might still be, was my favorite talk. Actually, it's after Sean Parent's C++ seasoning, but it's always been like a top three talk. There was like a phase where I went through
一堆声明式编程演讲，凯夫林·亨尼的声明式思考、声明式编程之类的内容。这两场简直是必看之作。当人们向我询问 C++ 演讲时，连同肖恩的 C++ 调味那次演讲、凯夫林·亨尼的演讲、还有你那个展示使用 std::accumulate 的多种方法的算法帝国演讲，在我看来绝对是必看的。总之，我们会把所有这些内容的播放列表链接到我的秘密播放列表中，因为我确实保留了一个播放列表，这样我可以追踪我自己的演讲，但我从不看它们。35 个视频，但其中包含在不同会议上重复的相同演讲，也包含闪电演讲。而且它还没有包含上周的演讲。我觉得我已经做了那么多演讲。我觉得我已经做了那么多演讲。是的，这不算巨量。我的意思是，如果你在某个地方做一次演讲，比如，我通常一年只去几个会议。
a bunch of like declarative programming talks, Kevlin Henney's declarative thinking, declarative programming, something like that. Those two are just like, they're like must watches. When people ask me for C++ talks, along with with sean c++ seasoning that talk kevin honey's talk um your uh algorithmic empire one where you show the ways to use stood to accumulate a bunch of different ways it's like a must watch my opinion anyways we'll we'll link the playlist to all of them on my secret playlist i have because i do keep a playlist so I can keep track of my own talks but I never watch them. 35 videos but that includes dupes
并且在每个会议上做一次演讲。不同之处在于，本做的演讲比我做的好得多。这里重点不在于数量，而在于质量。确实如此。也正因为如此，我尽量不这样做，我每个会议的上限是两个，通常是一个。是的，我想我提到的那些演讲的特点是，在演讲中有些话语会让你陷入思考，你会想：“哦，哇，这是一个很好的观点，我以前没有想过。”
with the same talks at different conferences and that includes lightning talks as well. And it doesn't yet have the talk from last week. I feel like I've given that many talks. I feel like I've given that many talks. Yeah, it's not a huge amount. I mean if you give one talk at, like, I typically only go to a couple of conferences a year.
比如，我记得我大概第一次看到立即调用的 Lambda 表达式被用作一种声明式的方法，用来实现 Kotlin 或类似语言中的 if 表达式。我想我不记得那是不是你用的确切例子，但你展示了那个，然后我想：“哦，太棒了。”而且你有一个演示，从前后对比中添加了一个常量。我当时就觉得，太棒了。我甚至可能之前在别的演讲中见过。我知道菲尔·纳什做过一些那样的演讲，但有时你在某个特定时间点观看演讲，它会在恰当的时机击中你。是的。
And I'll give a talk at each. The difference is that Ben gives much better talks than I give. It's not about the quantity here. It's about the quality. It is. And for that reason, I try not to, my maximum per conference is two and usually one yeah i think the the thing about those talks that i mentioned is like the number of times in a talk where something is said that like makes you think and you're like oh wow that's a good i didn't think
这些内容的链接，包括特里斯坦的演讲、本的演讲、会议等。也许，也许我们会把这期节目的第一部分，如果本——因为你刚刚在 C++ Now 度过了过去的一周——如果你想对你做的两次演讲做一个小小的回顾，并分享一些人们在 C++ Now 的内容开始上线时应该关注的亮点。嗯，会议的总体主题是安全和安全性，我们如何在 C++ 中做到这一点，如果在某些情况下我们可以在 C++ 中做到这一点，我们该如何实现。你们解决了吗？
about that before like i remember probably the first time I saw an immediately invoked Lambda expression used as like a declarative way to do like, you know, if expressions in Kotlin or something like that. And I think I can't remember if that was the exact example you used, but you showed that and I was like, oh, that's so nice. Like, and you had this thing where you went from before and after and added a constant. I was just like, that is, that's very nice. And I might've even seen it in another talk before. I know Phil Nash did some talks like that, but sometimes like you watch a talk at a certain point and it hits you at the right time. Yeah.
有答案吗？哦，是的。不，我们现在解决了。答案是什么？很好，太棒了。不，有很多不同的方法，对吧？
Links to all of those things for both Tristan's talks, Ben's talks, conferences, et cetera. Maybe, uh, maybe we'll make this first part of this episode if, if Ben, cause you just spent the last week at C++ now, if you want to give like a a little recap of the two talks you gave and like any highlights of things people should watch out when the c++ now things start coming on coming online uh well the the sort of overarching theme of the conference was safety and security how we do that in c++ if we can do that in c++ in some cases, how we might get there. Did you guys solve it?
是的，这就是会议的主题。我的两次演讲，嗯，我最初，是的，所以这就是会议的主题。我的两次演讲，嗯，我最初，我有，我提交了一个被接受了，为了（你知道的）保持演讲者多样性，这很酷。两者都经过了高度评审，然后，然后会议主席鲍勃·斯蒂格尔联系我，说：“你知道，你提交的另外这个演讲，你介意把它留在后备箱里，以防我们有演讲者来不了之类的情况吗？”确实，事情就是这样发生的。所以我最后做了一个演讲。那几乎是周一第一件事，周一早上。
Was there an answer? Oh, yeah. No, we solved it now. What's the answer? Yeah. Perfect. Great. No, there are lots of different approaches, right?
我替补了一个无法出席的演讲者。等等，等等，你是什么时候被通知需要做第二个演讲的？是像你到了会议现场，他们说“哦，对，我们需要你”吗？不，是提前几周。那还好。但那个演讲我已经在一个本地聚会和朋友们那里做过了，而且我已经做过大约三次了，所以我可以做那个。关于这个会议上 C++ Now 演讲者没有出席的那次的故事，我不知道，好吧，系好安全带！
Yeah, so that was the theme of the conference. My two talks, well, I originally, yeah so that was the theme of the conference my two talks um well i originally i had i had i submitted to one was accepted uh in the interest of you know just speaker diversity that's cool both were highly reviewed um and then and then bob bob stiegel the conference chair reached out to me and said you know this this other talk you submitted, would you mind sort of keeping it in the back pocket in case we have speakers who can't make it or whatever? And indeed, that's what happened. So I ended up giving one talk. It was pretty much first thing Monday, Monday morning.
座位边缘的我，想知道本做的这个演讲的标题是什么。让我们暂停这个故事。
I got subbed in for a speaker who couldn't make it wait wait when when were you informed that you needed to give the second talk was it like you showed up at the conference they're like oh yeah we need you no it was a couple of weeks before that that was okay but that talk i had already given at the local meetup and to friends and in uh i've already given it like three times so i can get that one the story on this conference about the time that a c++ now speaker didn't show up i don't all right strap strap yourselves in what the year i'm on i'm on the edge of my seat wanting to know the title of this talk that Ben gave. Let's pause this story.
我好像在等待。我在聚会上看过这个吗？还是说这是可观看的？这是一个新演讲吗？所以你在暂停布莱斯，还是在暂停我？是的，我们在暂停布莱斯。我们会让布莱斯讲这个故事。我向你保证，布莱斯。
I'm like waiting. Have I seen this one at a meetup? Or is this watchable? Is this a new talk? So are you pausing Bryce or are you pausing me? Yeah, we're pausing Bryce. We will let Bryce tell this story. I promise you, Bryce.
你稍等。他非常兴奋。他在前 20 分钟睡着了，但现在他醒了，因为他有一个精彩的故事要讲。所以第一个演讲的标题是《历法 C++》。等等，什么？《历法 C++》。我不明白。日历计算。
You hang on. He's very excited. He was asleep for the first 20 minutes, but now he's awake because he's got an exciting story to tell. So the first talk was entitled Calendrical C++. Wait, what? Calendrical C++. I don't understand. Calendar Calculations.
好的。好吧。现在我明白了。非常棒的是——这种情况经常发生——我提交了这个演讲，我想这是一个非常小众的话题。这是一个有趣且具有娱乐性的演讲。但在 C++ Now，我们的目标是让房间里的人玩得开心并学到一些东西，而不一定要求演讲具有很广泛的兴趣。我认为这是一个更好的目标。不管怎样，我提交了它，然后我看到，克服重重困难，
Okay. All right. Now I understand. And what was really nice, and this sort of often happens, is I submitted it and I thought this is a really niche topic. It's a fun and entertaining talk. But at C++ now, the goal is the people in the room have fun and learn something, not necessarily that the talk is of very wide interest. That's a better goal, I think. Anyway, so I submitted it and I saw that, against all odds, goal i think anyway so i submitted and i saw that against all
目标，我想，不管怎样，我提交了它，我看到克服重重困难，另一个关于日历计算的演讲也被提交了，它实际上与我的演讲非常互补。卡西奥·内里做了那个演讲，我在这次会议上第一次遇到了卡西奥，你知道的，由于我们对日历极客化有共同的兴趣，我们一拍即合。所以那是第一个演讲。我主要讲了如何计算复活节的日期。我们以前在播客里提到过这个。这不是引发过战争的事情吗？嗯，我不知道是不是特指复活节的日期。
odds another talk about calendar calculations was submitted and it was actually very complimentary with mine um cassio neri gave that one and um i met cassio for the first time this conference and you know with our common interest of geeking out about calendars we we hit it off straight away so that was the first talk. I talked mostly about how to calculate the date of Easter. So we've mentioned this on the podcast before. Is this not something that wars have been fought over? Well, I don't know about that specifically over the date of Easter.
确实，战争曾阻碍日历的更改，英国历史上有名的时期曾发生过冲突，起因是不同（也许这有点过于简单化，但）不同的阵营有不同的宗教信仰，并且至少有一个时期，两个教派之间的主要分歧之一是他们认为的复活节是什么，比如他们如何计算复活节的日期。我不知道有什么具体的战争，但这绝对不是不可能的。
It's true that the wars have hindered calendar changes, famously in times in the history of the British people where there have been conflicts fought over the different, maybe this is a little bit reductionist, but that different camps had different religious beliefs and that there was at least one period of time where one of the major differences between two sects was what they considered Easter, like how they calculated the date of Easter. I'm unaware of a specific war, but I mean, it's certainly not out of the realm of possibility.
有几种不同的相互竞争的计算方法。我们谈论的是，我想到了早期，或者说西罗马帝国的晚期。是的。特里斯坦，你刚才想说点什么。我只是想说，我不记得听说过，长期以来确实存在宗教事务，新教徒和天主教徒，
There were several different competing ways to calculate it. We're talking about the, I'm thinking of the early days, or let's say the late days of the Western Roman Empire. Yes. Tristan, you were going to say something. I was just going to say, I don't recall hearing, there had certainly been religious things, Protestants and Catholics for a very long time
是的，嗯，但我认为如今英国国教会和天主教会肯定在复活节使用相同的日期。我不知道它是否一直是这样。是的，所以它是由公元 325 年的第一次尼西亚公会议确定的。
yeah um but i think certainly these days the church of england the catholic church use the same date for easter i don't know if it's always been yes uh so it was fixed by the the first council of nicaea in 325 uh ce A little while ago then. Yeah. They tried to fix it because the Roman Empire was large and they couldn't really tell everyone this is when Easter is. You know, if you're living
那是挺久以前了。是的。他们试图修复它，因为罗马帝国很大，他们无法真正告诉每个人复活节是什么时候。你知道的，如果你生活在基督教的早期，你可能和犹太人是朋友，或者你自己以前就是犹太人。所以你可以问你的本地拉比逾越节是什么时候，然后你就知道复活节是什么时候了。但随着罗马帝国的发展和扩张，边远地区的人们没有这种能力。
in the very early days of Christianity, you probably are friends or used to be yourself Jewish. So you could ask your local rabbi when Passover is and then you would know when Easter is. But as the Roman Empire grew and expanded people on the fringes didn't have that capability
所以，他们试图修复它，他们基本上说春分是 3 月 21 日，他们将春分定义为 3 月 21 日，他们说复活节将是，我们将把春分当天或之后的第一个满月。然后我们将把之后的那个星期日定为复活节。
so well so they tried to fix it and they basically said the spring equinox is the 21st of March they defined that to be the 21st of March and they said Easter is going to be we'll take the first full moon on or after the spring equinox. And we will take the Sunday after that.
重要的是，如果满月恰好在星期日，你必须整整等上一周才能迎来下一个星期日。这很简单。你本以为。说起来很简单。东正教教会难道没有不同的日期吗？你说得完全正确。他们仍然遵循儒略历。哦，原来是这样，所以这就是不同之处。所以，是的，有两种算法，一种用于儒略历，一种用于 1583 年格里历改革后的格里历版本。但它们（我的意思是儒略历和格里历）是非常相似的日历。也许更有趣的一点信息是，我发现……
And importantly, if the full moon is on a Sunday, you have to wait a full week for the next Sunday. That's easy. You would think. Easy enough to say. Don't the Eastern Orthodox churches have a different date you are dead right they they still keep to the julian calendar oh is that what it okay so that was the difference there so yeah there are two algorithms one for the julian calendar and then after the gregorian reforms from 1583 the the gregorian calendar version but they're both i mean julian and gregorian are very similar calendars um what may be more interesting you know a tidbit of
嗯，我们在格里历中计算闰年的方法是众所周知的：每四年一次，除了每 100 年一次，除了每 400 年一次，对吧？也就是说，如果这一年是世纪年，它必须能被 400 整除。我想这次通话中的每个人可能都知道这一点，我们的大多数听众也知道。这是第一年的计算机科学常识。主要是因为我们在公元 2000 年都活得好好的。是的，是的。
information i found out was that um so the the way we calculate leap years in the gregorian calendar is well known it's every four years except except every hundred years except every 100 years, except every 400 years, right? Which is to say, if the year is a century, it has to be divisible by 400. I think everyone on this call probably knows that and most of our listeners do too. It's a first year CS sort of- Mostly because we were all alive in the year 2000. Yeah, yeah.
这是 FizzBuzz 级别的编程题，然后就像计算闰年一样。但是东正教会及其国家，几个主要是东欧的国家，没有采用相同的闰年算法——尽管它们在民用日历上使用的是格里历。它们不是每 800 年做两个世纪闰年，而是每 900 年做两个世纪闰年，至少目前来看，就地球绕太阳运行的方式而言，这稍微更精确一些。所以，它们在除以 900 之后，在余数为 200 和 600 的年份设立闰年，
It's fizzbuzz and then it's like calculating a leap year. But the Orthodox churches and their countries, several countries, Eastern European mostly, don't have the same, although they're on the Gregorian calendar as a civil calendar sort of thing, they don't have the same leap year algorithm. instead of doing two century leap years every 800 years, they do two century leap years every 900 years, which is at least at the moment, slightly more accurate with respect to how the earth goes around the sun. So, so they, they do the leap years on the 200s and the 600s after dividing by 900,
在对 900 取模之后。那么为什么没有人，有没有人尝试过搞公制时间或十进制时间？哦，是的。法国大革命时期就以这个闻名。确实如此。那对他们来说结果如何？嗯，关于日历，这没问题，如果你决定这样做的话，但世界其他地方也得这么决定。
after modding by 900. So why hasn't any, has anybody ever tried to do metric time or base 10 time? Oh, yeah. The French Revolutionary period was famous for that. That's right. How did that work out for them? Well, the thing about calendars is it's fine, but it's fine if you decide that, but the rest of the world kind of has to decide that.
你可能也会感兴趣地了解到，1928 年英国通过了一项法案，将复活节的日期固定在 4 月第二个星期六之后的星期日。该法案获得通过，但正如人们所说的那样，从未付诸实施。目前还不清楚“付诸实施”究竟意味着什么，但它基本上意味着从来没有哪个教会关注过它，而他们才是真正决定复活节的人。如果英国单方面决定……也许会更混乱。
It may also interest you to know that in 1928, the UK passed an act fixing the date of Easter to the Sunday after the second Saturday in April. And that law was passed and never brought into force, as they say. It's unclear quite what brought into force means, but it basically means no church has ever paid attention to it, and they're the people who really decide Easter. Perhaps it would be more confusing if the UK unilaterally decided that
这就像 C++ 11 中的垃圾回收，你知道的，它在技术上是一个没有编译器实现的功能，后来他们在某个时候把它去掉了。一两周前，我听到有人向我表达了这样的观点：
it's like garbage collection in C++ 11 you know it was technically a thing that no compiler implemented and then they just removed it at some point a week or two ago I heard somebody somebody expressed to me that
他们很高兴看到 C++11 中增加了对垃圾回收的支持。我对此感到有点惊讶。嗯，它被拿掉了。是的，我知道。那他们可能对看到它被移除感到难过。我实在不忍心告诉他们它已经被移除了。你知道，你在这里听到的是高度浓缩的版本，我就讲到这里，
garbage collection that they were happy to have seen garbage collection support added in C++11. And I was a little bit surprised by that. Well, it got taken out. Yeah, I know. They were sad to see it removed then, perhaps. I did not have the heart to tell them it had been removed. You know, what you're getting here is the very condensed version and i'll cut it off there
因为我钻研这个兔子洞已经大约一年了。所以当时实际发生的情况是，艾娃对我说：“你知道，你一直在读书，你花了这么多时间了解所有这些东西，你最好做个演讲。我想看到这不仅仅是一堆冷门知识。”不，不，不。别再跟我谈这个了。去跟其他人谈，这样我就不用再听了。是的，是的。
because because i've been going down the rabbit hole for like a year and so what actually happened there was ava said to me you know you've you've been reading books you've been spending so much time learning about all this stuff you'd better make a talk out of this i want to see i want to see this amount to something other than just a bunch of trivia. No, no, no. Stop talking to me about this. Talk to other people about this so I don't have to hear this anymore. Yeah, yeah.
看呐。你在 C++ Now 上交到了一位挚友，他同样对完全相同的事情充满极客热情。是的，所以卡西奥的演讲是关于计算自纪元以来的天数转换，将自纪元以来的天数转换为年、月、日，反之亦然。好的，所以这有点像——其实我不知道它在 Excel 中是如何运作的，但有点像 Excel 的那种功能。你没有选择正确的数字格式，结果得到一个大数字。不，我想，是的。大致来说，我其实不确定他们是否使用——在 Excel 中好像使用的是 1970 年左右的某个东西，所以我觉得那不是一回事。不管怎样，那是我的备用演讲。我的真正的演讲——我在 C++ Now 上推出的新演讲——是关于
And look at that. You made like a best friend at C++ Now that also nerds out about the exact same thing. Yeah, so Casio's talk was about the calculation for changing between days since epoch, converting days since epoch into year, month, day, and vice versa. Okay, so it's like a little – well, actually, I don't know how it works in Excel, but something like that Excel thing. You don't select the right number format and you get this big number. No, I guess, yeah. Roughly speaking, I'm not actually sure if they use – use like 1970 something i think in excel so i don't i don't think that's the same thing but anyway so that was my backup talk my my sort of real talk my my my talk which was new for c++
applicative 函子。哦，范畴论。我把它叫作，忘了——其实不是范畴论，我不是一个狂热的范畴论研究者，我崇尚实用性。但，我的意思是，那确实是范畴论的一个术语，对吧？当然，如果你喜欢的话。对我来说，这是来自学习 Haskell 和函数式编程的术语。是的，它确实来自范畴论，但演讲的副标题是“被遗忘的函数式模式”，因为我觉得，这个演讲的起源是我阅读每月在 C++ 邮件列表上发表的论文，看到所有这些被提议的东西，看到人们说“函子这个，单子那个”，并且，你知道的，我们为 optional 提供了单子函数，我们为 optional 提供了单子函数，我们为
now was about uh applicative functors oh category theory i called it the forgot well not cat i'm not a big category theorist i go in for practicalities but um i mean that that is a term from category theory though is well sure if you like for me it's a term from you know learning haskell and functional programming and uh yeah it it is from category theory but the subtitle of the talk was the forgotten functional pattern because i feel like you know the genesis of this talk was me reading papers that come out every month on the c++ mailing and seeing all these things proposed and seeing people say you know functor this and monad that and and you know we have monadic functions for optional we have monadic functions for optional we have monadic
expected 提供了单子函数（尽管它没有被广泛大肆宣扬），发送者-接收者提议是基于延续单子的，但从来没有人提到过 applicative，而它超级有用。这就是我的演讲内容。好吧，我会放上链接。好吧，所以事情大概会这样发展：这些内容会慢慢推出。所以我会把未链接的链接放在节目说明中，并在这些 C++ Now 视频上线时更新它们。
functions that expected although it's not widely fan uh trumpeted uh the senders receivers proposal is based on you know uh the continuation monad but nobody ever mentions applicative and uh it's super useful. So that was what my talk was about. Well, I will put links. Well, so probably the way it's going to work is these things are going to get rolled out slowly. So I will put unlinked links in the show notes and I will update them as these C++ Now videos.
你接下来还会在其他任何会议上做这些演讲吗？或者我知道你要去 C++。我要去 C++ Now 的视频。你接下来还会在其他任何会议上做这些演讲吗？我知道你要去 C++。我要去 C++ North。是的，我是那里的主题演讲嘉宾，我需要弄清楚我的主题演讲会讲什么。没关系。你还有几个月时间。我还有几个月时间。
Are you going to be giving these talks at any other conferences coming up? Or I know you're going to be at C++. I'm going to be at C++ Now videos. Are you going to be giving these talks at any other conferences coming up? I know you're going to be at C++. I'm going to be at C++ North. Yeah, I'm keynoting there, and I need to figure out what my keynote will be. It's all right. You've got a couple of months. I've got a couple of months.
不过我在我的 applicative 演讲中为你准备了一个专门的 Nerd Snipe（极客恶作剧），康纳。哦，是的。我在想，你有你的标志性单子演讲，这也是极棒的演讲。你会把——你刚才说这不是关于范畴论，但你是否要把这个范畴论，你是否在搞一个非官方的范畴论相关系列演讲，针对那些实用主义的……这不是，我不是从这个目标出发的。不，我的目标是展示碰巧被证明非常实用的函数式编程技术的实际应用，我发现这些技术真的很有用，而且我认为更多人可以通过了解它们而受益。我并不是试图制作一套范畴论相关的作品。有趣。好吧，你看起来有点像一个迷你版巴尔塔日（去掉全盘范畴论兔子洞的部分），但，你知道的，为不懂抽象数学只想在代码中使用模式的人准备的范畴论。是的，你可以这么看。关于这个 applicative 演讲，我强调的一点是，也许人们不太使用它的原因是因为每个人都在 Haskell 的公式中解释它，而这对于 C++ 来说并不是一个特别有用的公式。所以我采取了不同的方法，我试图用一种更适用于 C++ 的不同公式来解释它。有趣。我将翘首以盼它的发布。听起来确实非常有趣。
But I did put in my applicative talk a special Nerd Snipe for you, Connor. Oh, yeah. I was thinking that you've got your identifying monoids talk which is also fantastic talks are you putting i mean you just said it's not about category theory but are you putting this category are you making like a unofficial category theory adjacent series of talks for like the plaque the practical well that's not i'm not working from that goal no uh my my goal is you know to expose practical
是的，这也完全符合你的胃口，特里斯坦。函数式风格、面向集合的编程。还有什么你想强调的或者人们应该关注的东西吗？
applications of what happened to be functional programming techniques that that i find really useful and i think more people could benefit from knowing about um i'm not trying to uh you know produce an oeuvre of category theory adjacent work interesting well you you're you seem like you're kind of like a mini bartage you know minus the uh full-blown uh category theory uh rabbit hole but uh you know category theory for person that doesn't understand abstract mathematics and just wants to have patterns to use in code yeah i mean you could look at that way when one of the things about this applicative talk was i highlighted like um maybe the reason why people don't use it so much is because everyone everyone explains it in the haskell formulation and that is not a
关于 C++ Now 上推出的内容？安全性已经解决了，所以我想我们期待一些详细说明这一点的演讲或公告。有什么最喜欢的演讲吗？很难挑选。我确实很喜欢
particularly useful formulation for c++ so i took a different tack I tried to explain it with a different formulation, which is much more applicable to C++. Interesting. I will be waiting on the edge of my seat for this to be released. That definitely does sound very interesting. Yeah, it's right up your alley too, Tristan. Functional style, collection-oriented programming. Any other things you want to highlight or things people should watch out for
我去听的所有演讲中的大多数。今年 C++ Now 恢复了全盛状态。有哪些演讲是你没看上的？不，不，只是没有哪个是我不喜欢的。它们都很好。关于其他主题，我试图想一想。蒂穆尔做了一个分两部分的
on the interwebs coming out of C++ now? Safety's been solved, so I guess we look forward to some talk or some announcement detailing that. Any favorite talks? It's hard to pick. I did enjoy
关于低延迟 C++ 的演讲，很有意思，因为——曾在游戏和金融领域工作过，当然蒂穆尔在音频领域工作过很多——思考这些领域之间的区别很有趣。
most of the all of the talks I went to. It was, C++ Now was back up to full strength this year. Which talks didn't you like? No, no, it was just, there were none that I did not like. They were all good. On other topics, I'm trying to remember. Timur gave a two-parter
真正的巨大区别是硬截止时间。可以说是硬截止时间。我的意思是，如果没有赶上截止时间，希望没有人会死。但在音频和游戏中，当需要渲染下一帧声音或下一帧游戏时，你有一个硬性截止时间。而在金融领域，你有一个截止时间，但你不知道它是什么，你只必须比下一个人更快。这是一个不同种类的……事情。所以在很多情况下，你在优化……当你有一个音频方面的硬截止时间时，你是在优化最坏情况，你希望最坏情况保持在那个截止时间之内。而在金融领域，你不是在优化以将最坏情况保持在截止范围内，你是在优化以在最好情况下做到最快。很有意思。是的，我以前从没想过这一点。这是一种有趣的看待方式。好吧，我们会把蒂穆尔的两次演讲链接放上去，我相信会有一个 2023 年 C++ Now 播放列表，我们会将其链接起来，供感兴趣的人观看。好的，我们结束 C++ Now 这一集的讨论（本次讨论的第一部分），接下来我们将过渡到……
on low latency C++ that was interesting because it's and it's interesting having worked in games and finance and of course Timor's worked a lot in audio interesting to sort of think about the differences between those
等等，稍等。我们得讲我的故事。好的，这个故事要讲多久？我不知道，直到我开始讲之前我其实并不知道。好吧，听众朋友们，根据这个故事有多么有趣，我们可能会听到一个花栗鼠声音的布莱斯。不过请继续，布莱斯。这是一个好故事。如果你快进过掉这个，听众会造反的。
the big difference really is hard deadlines. So hard-ish. I mean, nobody dies if you miss the deadline, hopefully. But in audio and in games, you have a hard deadline for when the next frame of sound needs to be rendered or when the next frame of the game needs to be rendered. Whereas in finance, you have a deadline deadline you don't know what it is you just have to be faster than the next person it's a it's a it's a different sort of um thing so you're optimizing for in many cases you're optimizing for the you know when you have a hard deadline in audio you're optimizing for the
不。他们会不高兴的。这取决于听众是谁。我了解我的人。如果听众是扎克，我想他会挺高兴的——他们会不高兴的。这取决于听众是谁。我了解我的人。如果听众是扎克，我想他会挺高兴的，因为他亲自跟我说过。好吧。
the worst case you want to stay you want the worst case to stay within that deadline whereas in finance you are not optimizing to keep the worst case in a deadline you're optimizing for being fastest in the best case probably interesting yeah i never actually thought about that it's an interesting way of looking at it all right well we'll put team put two more links to Team Wars Talks, and I'm sure there's a C++ Now 2023 playlist that we'll link, so those that are interested. All right, we'll wrap the C++ Now episode, part one of this discussion, and we will transition.
有人没出现。发生了什么事？那是……我记得。我在现场。你在现场。我不知道你是不是其中之一。除了说话的钱德勒之外，我不记得任何人。但我知道钱德勒演示了
Wait, hang on. We've got to do my story. Okay, how long is this story going to take? I don't know. I never really know until I get into it. All right. Well, listener, we might be listening to a little chipmunk Bryce here, depending on how entertaining this story is. But you go ahead, Bryce. This is a good story. If you fast forward through this, the listener is going to revolt.
我想他演示了心脏出血漏洞。我想他确实演示了心脏出血漏洞，是的。利用模糊测试。然后他就再也没有出现过了。再也没有出现过了。所以，随你们怎么想吧。让我们打个五星好评吧，
No. They're going to be unhappy. It depends on who the listener is. I know my people. If the listener is Zach, I think he's going to be quite happy about They're going to be unhappy. It depends on who the listener is. I know my people. If the listener is Zach, I think he's going to be quite happy about it because he told me personally. All right.
特里斯坦，本，我们对这个故事怎么看？记住我是你的朋友。别忘了我……我的意思是，如果你没什么好话可说，那就什么也别说。它在加速。它在加速，我要……是什么来着？三星评分就像是对会议挺好，但可能存在一些问题。我要把它加速，然后再慢下来，正好配合本的声音。特里斯坦会很好的。我很抱歉。我很抱歉。我道歉。
Someone didn't show up. What happened? The year is... I remember this. I was there. You were there. I don't know if you were one of the people. I don't remember anyone other than Chandler who talked. But I know that Chandler demoed
这就是麻烦所在，因为我已经这样做好几次了。我开始感觉更自如了。而且，你知道的，我所有的，一切现在都冒出来了。我不能再假装友好了。我最喜欢的嘉宾是那些吐槽布莱斯的嘉宾。我不认为扎克——我的意思是，很显然肖恩就是……肖恩就是肖恩。但扎克，我从来没有因为扎克说“好吧，布莱斯，安静点”而笑得这么厉害。
I think he demoed Heartbleed. I think he did demo Heartbleed, yeah. With fuzzing. And he was never heard from again. Never heard from again. So, do with that what you will. Let's just get like out of five
安静点，布莱斯。我们懂了。扎克绝对是 C++ 圈里最搞笑的人之一。是的，他太搞笑了。不过我最喜欢的是扎克和大卫·森克尔互动的时候。那两人。哦，是的。是的。
stars, Tristan, Ben, how do we feel about that story remember that i am your friend don't remember that i um i mean i i i if you haven't got anything nice to say then don't say anything at all it's getting sped up it's getting sped up and i'm gonna what is it the three-star rating is like would be good for the conferences but issues may exist i'm gonna speed it up and then slow it down right for ben's voice tristan would be nice. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I apologize.
大卫带着他的孩子们做的演讲，依然是我看过的最喜欢的节目之一。我太震惊他能做这个了。我甚至不记得标题了。好像是单子、函子和 applicative 函数之类的。函数式模式，是的。是的。他在 CPPCon 上做了这个演讲。那是预先录制的，所以他把他的孩子们也录进去了。
That's the trouble because I've done this several times now. I'm beginning to feel a bit more comfortable. Yeah. And, you know, all of my, everything's coming out now. I can't pretend to be nice anymore. My favorite guests are the ones that roast Bryce. I don't think Zach, I mean, obviously Sean is, you know, Sean is Sean. But Zach, I don't think I've laughed so hard from Zach just being like, all right, Bryce, quiet down.
这就是问题所在，因为我已经做过好几次了。我开始觉得舒服多了。是的。而且，你知道，我的所有东西现在都展现出来了。我再也不能假装是个好人了。我最喜欢的嘉宾是那些狠狠吐槽布莱斯的嘉宾。我不觉得扎克——我的意思是，显然肖恩就是——你知道，肖恩就是肖恩。但扎克，我觉得我从来没有因为扎克说“好了，布莱斯，安静点”而笑得这么大声过。
Quiet down, Bryce. We get it. Zach legitimately has to be one of the funniest people in C++. Yeah, he's hilarious. My favorite thing, though, is when Zach and David Sankel interact together. Those two are. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
安静点，布莱斯。我们懂的。扎克绝对是C++圈里最好笑的人之一。是的，他太搞笑了。不过我最喜欢的是扎克和大卫·桑克尔（David Sankel）互动的时候。那两个人真是。哦，对。是的。
David's talk with his kids, still one of my favorite things that I've ever. I was so shocked he gave this. I can't even remember the title. It was like monoids, monads, and applicative functions or something. Functional patents, yeah. Yeah. And he gave it at CPPCon. And it was pre-recorded, so he had his kids in it.
大卫和他的孩子们的演讲，仍然是我看过的最喜欢的节目之一。我很震惊他做了这个。我甚至记不清标题了。好像是幺半群、单子和应用函数之类的。函数式模式，是的。是的。而且他是在CPPCon上讲的。那是预先录制的，所以他的孩子们也出镜了。
And he had them like, it was as if he was teaching them category theory and had them act out little bits and like, what's a monad? Well, glad you asked, kids. It was just so entertaining. Be sure to check your show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to any of the talks or topics that we mentioned in today's episode. As well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave comments, questions, we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave comments, questions, or thoughts on today's episode. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他还让他们就像是在教他们范畴论一样，让他们表演一些小片段，比如“什么是单子？很高兴你们问起，孩子们。”真是太有趣了。请务必查看您的播客应用中或访问 ADSPthepodcast.com 的节目简介，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何演讲或主题的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论区的链接，您可以在那里留下对今天节目的评论、问题或想法。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。